it's a great look Kim Kardashian
continues to prove that her house is the
epitome of minimalistic rich that type
of wealth where if it looks simple it's
probably really expensive it's amazing
Kim recently showed her bathroom balcony
on her in story which basically looks
like a tropical forest beautiful yes but
there is one detail that will blow your
mind she revealed that from time to time
they changed the design of the balcony
as if it was a museum installation right
now it's quote full of fresh lavender I
want something that I feel like calms me
is healing now this isn't the first time
we've seen her bizarre bathroom
that's our patio out there our whole
ceiling is a lightbox bathtub fits all
of our kids and I shower the reason the
mama for decided to give us a tour of
her bathroom in the first place was
because people were super confused about
her sinks and the fact that they appear
to be flat so the sinks Kanye drew this
Kanye Axl Valora and Claudia Sylvester
in kind of all did this sink and Claudia
was the one that said it should be
separated from the wall because it used
to be up against the wall but we thought
it would be cooler this way so eight
versions of this prototype sink was made
and it does actually like slightly
sloped down that you can kind of see and
there's a slit for the water you can put
it on as high pressure as you want and
no backsplash will come up
Kanye's creativity is definitely
showcased throughout the house not too
long ago Kim spoke to et about Kanye's
budding interest in architecture we went
on an architecture trip
he loves architecture so we went to go
meet with some Japanese architects and
see some James Turrell exhibits in a
museum on an island off of Japan so it
was really amazing a few weeks ago Kim
posted a picture in front of a
half-empty refrigerator which made fans
wonder how does she feed her kids Kim
then put to shame every basic
refrigerator and gave us a tour of her
multiple fridges pantries and freezers
right now was just my drink fridge all
my kids use a different kind of milk
with you guys my fresh juices fresh
water that's all that's in this fridge
however let me show you something buy
something she means another fridge this
is the kitchen where it all happens
say hi marina and guys I have walk-in
frigerator where we keep all of our
fresh organic produce
we are building on the property of
organic trees to grow our own vegetables
and do all of our own stuff so this all
of our meals and another one then you
know this deliciousness then if you want
a little more chaos with tons of oat
milk and almond milk you have this
frigerator okay then if you want freezer
I didn't even show you guys are other
freezer there you have it guys thanks
Kim well at least one thing is for sure
the internet lives for Kimberly's house
tours even if it makes them feel a wee
bit poor
[Music]